by the power of castle hate school i am
lamar carley and you are back again and
i appreciate it because here we are
episode 21 as casey just told me he made
this joke and i thought about stealing
it and being like oh that was my own
joke but he said this episode is old
enough to drink let's give it up for
casey
internet's most handsome podcast
producer and one of the best
off-the-cuff joke writers in this room
right now
kristen you're also great to talk
i love doing that when it's like you
know one of the person like yo you're
the best looking person in this room
pretty small sample size small sample
size christian's also very funny
christian you're doing stand-up now i am
that's freaking awesome yeah it's uh
been been a lot of fun uh
definitely gonna keep at it and just for
fun because it's a great feeling yeah i
think you're you're born to do it so
let's all leave a comment down below
it's some encouragement for christian to
keep doing stand-up because i think he's
going to do
big things a short king doing big things
so all right you know i want to start
off instead of subfold this time i want
to do
some more hey that hurts we haven't done
that in a while and you know i don't
want to give
the haters on the internet really too
much
name recognition so from now when i read
these things i'm just going to say
haters will say and then something that
i read about myself on the internet that
i thought was hurtful it was mean
spirited and uh not true as well so
haters will say i look like china's
failed attempt to create brad pitt using
gene editing technology
like ah that didn't work let's try again
but in a chinese accent haters will say
mark looks like a less talented and
handsome kevin dillon chris
christian that was you wasn't it
on your burner no okay no
not good one no yeah i'll um
yeah we'll see about that okay let's see
what kind of comments a random anonymous
account
leaves on your picks this week who knows
probably something equally hurtful
haters will say this podcast is secretly
funded by the lip filler industry it's
not though because i think i would know
you know they would tell me that they'd
be like mark this influx of cash that we
recently got along with the
encouragement for you to do even more
lip fillers
like i think i would get that memo but i
haven't unless
casey christian and brendan are all
profiting
off this dark lip filler money and i
have no idea about it which if that
comes to light i mean you're going to
see this you're going to go back that
was the mark the moment mark realized
that's definitely not the case
what that's crazy
big lip filler industry what
that's not even a thing
haters will say mark is very unlikable
for somebody with mild autism i but see
that's just not true like i don't
it's full-blown autism
haters will say my 12 year old niece got
cut from her youth soccer team due to
tripping so much over her own feet at
practice that she became a legal
liability but she's still significantly
more athletic than mark that's like such
a long setup
to call me unathletic i feel like
did you need to go into that much detail
you know and i'd frankly
i'd like to see your 12 year old niece
let's do a head-to-head let's do some
agility drills let's put it on the line
if you even exist 12 year old niece
and finally haters will say mark
displays the classic cte symptoms of his
cognition slowly degrading over time
while simultaneously believing
unironically that he's getting more
intelligent every day
see that's not even true because i just
think i've remained that that constant
very high level of intelligence
over time so again fact check turns out
you're wrong
five pinocchios
all right so what's up fool what's up
with you guys you guys can tell me about
your week in the comments and i can riff
on that sometimes because funny stuff
comes out remember the guy
the other week well this wasn't part of
his week but
i'm never gonna get over him telling me
you know yeah my sister was burning
inside the house and i was like damn my
parents are gonna be pissed if i let her
go up in flames
because they're mexican
oh my god so this weekend i had possibly
the worst restaurant experience in my
entire life it was a comedy of errors i
did a photo shoot on sunday uh for a
friend of mine from the gym named josh
and he's
launching a supplement line and wanted
to you know talked about getting in and
getting some photos and so we arranged
all this and like
got the clothes got the photographer you
know had multiple models like you know
talk to 24 fitness set all this up and i
know that can be really stressful i
think if you're if you're the guy in
charge of everything it's not stressful
for me to show up and you like shoot as
an actor or uh you know be the model in
a photo shoot because you don't have to
do much but when you're organizing
things
obviously there's more tension and
pressure and that is setting up the fact
that afterwards we're like we're going
to go to buffalo wild wings and just
have a beer and some wings and relax
after this you know it took a few hours
and i think he was stressed because
various people had time pressures and
whatnot so
uh after that we're like yeah let's go
get some wings now to set this up
we uh
i've been to buffalo wild wings only a
few times in my life
i feel like every time i've gone i'm
like
they should be better at making wings
like the wings taste good but like
something about the process of like
don't tell me to show up to your
restaurant if i order
you know it's going to be ready in 20
minutes and then i show up and it's like
45 minutes and i'm like there's nobody
in this restaurant like
how hard is it to cook 30 wings in a
establishment that i assume has multiple
fryers or whatever or this is the
primary thing that you do it's on the
menu it's one of the only things right
it's in the it's in the title i mean um
so i've had a couple experiences where
i'm like
they were oddly bad at making wings for
a place that has wings in the name of
the restaurant this was no exception
well i shouldn't say that it wasn't so
much the making of the wings this time
it was the logistical execution of
getting us our food and
uh communicating
through
some technical difficulties and
respectful where we come in first of all
the whole coveted thing now is like
selectively enforced in los angeles you
guys notice this where it's like
some restaurants will make you show the
id and the vax card and be kind of
strict about it and you know it's just
like hit or miss right so we walk up and
you know you're with a couple people who
just came from the gym it's like oh do i
have my like you know license on me and
my vax card like it's on my phone so
that just like can take a few minutes
because you're like looking forward
getting it and there was this the
photographer was like spanish and he
kind of like was like i have a mask i'm
like why do i need to show my id and my
va you know like if you have a few
questions in there like why are we doing
this and you know so it's like felt like
10 minutes to get through the hostess
and then she's like okay so you guys
want to sit down like actually we
ordered food ahead of time because you
put in an order 30 minutes at a time and
then we wanted to sit down and eat that
food that we had ordered ahead of time
turns out that's a big problem
we
uh she hands us off to like a service
the guy who seats us and they're like so
you're gonna order and we're like
actually we got food
like
we pre-ordered to eat it harry's like
ooh i don't know i don't know you're
like okay then like another person comes
and like we're seated but he's like i
need to go talk to everybody's like i
need to go talk to i need to go to i
need to go you know it was like whoa
like food that was ordered ahead of time
but you wanted to eat it on the table oh
my god what are we gonna do
now albeit the context of everything a
lot of new people a lot of people you
know
it's hard to find employees in the job
market so all this is going around and i
don't ever mean to like impugn
restaurant work you know
your job probably sucks you don't want
to be there i get it but it was this is
comedy of errors of like every person we
got handed off to like then we get a new
server and they come up like okay can i
take order like actually we already
ordered we told that to two people now
you're trying to get our order and he's
like oh yeah uh we don't do uh like he
goes to like the manager the manager
comes out like
it is like um um
yeah so here's the thing like here's
your food like we don't uh sorry this
was in the manager this is somebody from
the kitchen who came out like with our
food in bags and like you want to eat
this here and it was like super
confusing and like
uh we were
at this table that we're like hey can we
sit there like where do you want to sit
we're like let's we sit in the booth
like no there's like nobody there but
you can't see it's like that's not a
section right now it's like okay so half
the restaurant i can't sit in
sure let's go over here why did you just
ask me where i want to sit we go over
there the restaurant's closed they're
acting like oh yeah you could go in the
booth if you wait 20 minutes for what
there's three people in here we go and
sit down the server is like confused
somebody brings out our food and like
you want to eat this then they have to
go back and put it on plates and that
takes like 10 minutes and the server
walks by and he's like everything okay
he does like a drive-by everything okay
and i had to make no hey wait wait
we actually want can we get some drinks
it's been 20 minutes and we're still
trying to figure out how to eat the
cooked food
so
it sounds like that scene in 40 year old
virgin where jonah hill's trying to buy
something in the store but they only
sell the stuff online and he's like i
feel like i could just give you money
and you give me this and she's like
right i wish it was that easy this is a
very simple solution and i understand
there might be some policy but it's like
are you that worried about losing your
job because you put food that we paid
for on a plate like you know as if it's
established
some dangerous precedent because that's
what it ended up being like the manager
eventually comes out and he's like like
you know they're like okay we're gonna
do this for you but just this once and
um like just know that we don't do that
it felt like i was getting dressed down
by a principal it was weird it was like
okay because he kept repeating i was
like hey guys i'm so you know like
normally when i do this but i can
comment that's the
tone you'd expect instead it was like
guys um so
we don't do this this is not something
buffalo wild wings does we do not put
pre-ordered food on a plate for you to
eat here don't ever try this again or
you will be banned from the restaurant
you understand do you are we clear like
it felt like it was veering towards that
i'm like yeah dude i did not want to
cause any trouble by calling into order
wings and then wanting to eat them here
please can we eat them or not you know
and then
then they bring it out and the guy josh
who had set the whole thing up and he
was paying for dinner they [ __ ] up his
order they bring out
bone in instead of boneless like you
wanted so after that like half an hour
of waiting and haggling and being
reprimanded by the high school principal
slash assistant manager it's like okay
great now he [ __ ] it up he's like dude
like
oh my god and then
they bring
okay we'll make the right one then they
bring it out and [ __ ] his order up again
and at that point he's like dude are you
serious like i'm not paying for this you
know like you [ __ ] up so many times
you've been rude to us you passed this
off all these things are happening it's
like
at that point as a server a lot of
people would just go oh yes we made
multiple [ __ ] ups we're gonna do
something for you two to make this right
instead the response was
if you don't pay for this i'm calling
the cops it was like the first thing
that happened and so then now josh is
pissed off he's like because it's like
you wanna like you wanna be fair it's
like all right i wanna i don't wanna you
know i just ate my wings and drink a
beer like i don't wanna skip out on that
but then someone's like defying you you
know it's like oh yeah i'm gonna call
the cops it's like oh yeah when they
gonna get here because i can walk out of
the door right so we were actually
sitting at the table like are we about
to like
just
bust out of this buffalo wild wings you
know like break through the door like
heads down like they're gonna try to
grab us and make us pay we're like get
the [ __ ] off me just juggernaut it
through the through the exit um you get
arrested it's like what are you in for
it's like i was eating wings at out of
wing
for wings
but that was a legitimate conversation
and part of me did want to do it but
part of me was like oh god like i'm not
as worked up as josh's because it's like
he felt responsible for the whole thing
he was stressed out about and kind of
just wanted to have this nice thing so
ultimately it did kind of escalate i
think he just needed to like vent like
you're like this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
like are you out of your mind like this
you know a b c d and e to someone who
like wasn't involved from the very first
step so they hashed it out they gave us
a discount he's like let's meet in the
middle but um it was like now i'll
probably go back there to be honest i
don't blame any particular person like
it's the context it's the pandemic
there's all these difficulties going on
i hope you're like oh my god it's this
chinese surface it's like you're out of
buffalo wild wings like you know ghosts
you're not at a steak house like there
are just different expectations you have
to set and i sympathize for every person
working there because
you know
like you they probably don't want to be
there or they're probably new at the job
but it was just like i'm good at things
like that like as it's happening just
being like
i part of me wants to be angry but
mostly i just want to laugh at it right
now like it's like keep keep it coming
because this is going to make the story
immediately i'm like i'm going to tell
the story of the podcast um shout out
buffalo wild wings and sherman oaks i'll
give you another chance but if you [ __ ]
up again
it's over between us okay
and uh
let's just jump right into these liver
king memes of the week i'm always going
to share a video
so video opens up
on two needles
full of a dark steroid that looks like
trend i stacked blood-burning workouts
twice a day he's telling us a stack and
if you stack the nine ancestral tenants
you too can express your most dominant
form and
by the way this was my camera's man idea
so tip of the hat to him i don't even
know where to get this done
ah i didn't see that part i actually
goes i don't even know where to get this
stuff
i don't even okay so
that's actually a concrete denial of
being on steroids although people think
that sounds like more comp like jake was
like i don't even know what peds are
it's like oh yeah well of course like
you know you have to know what the
acronym ped stands for if you're gonna
be on steroids like you know i don't
even know how to get started doesn't
matter you could have your assistant get
them and still you know inject them in
your ass every day the only relevant
question is are they in your body which
obviously they are so
i think it's really funny that he like
as a marketing tactic it's brilliant
right because he's going
uh you know
how do i use this that that that does
create viral clips it does create this
um constant you know i'm talking about
him other people are talking about him
arguing in the comments blah blah he's
milking this natty or not thing for all
it's worth
and so as a marketing tactic ethics
aside
bravo you know you've you've managed to
like flirt with this steroid thing and
and make it this uh
you know eye capturing
thumbnail and then totally disavow
yourself of it immediately afterwards
like oh what do i stack you know i stick
stunts you know what that sounds like it
sounds like lance armstrong
oh really great mind sink alike huh um
where he goes
what am i on i'm on my bike eight hours
a day what do you want it's like oh
you you're on you're on it all buddy
so this whole idea of like it's so
ridiculous that people ask me what i'm
on oh god the balls you must have to
just like look people in the face and be
like what like
i don't even know what steroids are you
know
sure
um
so
as i said as a marketing tactic a1 10
out of 10.
as an ethical practice
i don't like it because i just think
he's continuing to exploit people's
naivete with regards to steroids he's
making an active denial like i thought
that video was skirting around at first
which kind of was it was like playful
with the steroids i don't even know this
is my cameraman
i've never even seen a needle in my life
obvious utter [ __ ] and i think he's
using
again deception
to make money off of people banking on
their naivete and i don't think that's
right to do in virtually any context
let's click on that second link
oh [ __ ] it's a private account so what
it is
it's uh i'm gonna describe this little
video it's a guy looking at grass-fed
beef organs like the supplement bottle
from the liver king
and he's looking at the nutrition facts
turning it around and then he opens it
up
and inside our two syringes
and uh you know some actually multiple
compounds like tran and you know
masteron and anavar and stuff like that
so i thought that was clever and it kind
of like even though that was made before
this actually before the liver king just
put out that video this is highly
relevant okay
another thing that i'm not going to have
a visual for because i think the
comments got deleted before i could
screenshot them but it's a hater of the
week
um
i was on my buddy not shulk's page
a dude who works out at zoo has an
amazing physique claims to be natty i
believe him
just because i don't know why he would
lie about it like i don't think he has a
huge incentive and all his friends are
like who do take steroids are more open
about it so but he just has a crazy
physique if you haven't seen him uh not
shulk he's extremely lean and vascular
now
so this is on somebody else's page and
we got to this like i said something and
this guy was like this random dude was
like nice frosted tips like nice frosted
hair and i was like oh
god but like
you're trying to talk to me it's like
what if i told you
that i haven't frosted my hair in 20
years you know since i was a
senior in high school and even that i
didn't frost you know the idea of
frosting my tips i would bleach the [ __ ]
out of my hair
and then i would grow it out
before the whole in sync boy band thing
that was a punk rock casey do you
remember this can i get some affirmation
of a person who is not 30 years younger
than me yeah like
bleached hair yeah was a southern
california punk look right and so you
would like did you ever bleach your hair
do any legs no i was back in the east
coast at that time okay i reckon i get
beat up for something like that
but yeah that was like that was the cool
thing and i even bleached my hair one
time like because you start with seventh
grade you start with sun in i don't know
if you know there's another probably
california thing where it's like
lightening your hair but we all wanted
like this dark ass hair at the time we
all want a blonde hair but you don't
realize it's like yeah put a little
peroxide in it doesn't do [ __ ] like
cinnamon's basically peroxide so you'd
like then you'd go to the l'oreal like
you progressively try to get the
stronger bleach even with pretty strong
bleach i'm still going to get like an
orange yellow tint to it so i was like
what if i just put straight bleach in my
hair
you know that was my home like ah
so i i decided to do like a test strand
like right around here
and i had like shaved under like lungs
you know
they're like that in the mid 90s put
this strand of hair in a bowl of just
pure bleach not watered down whatsoever
and after like a minute like i came out
like oh [ __ ] it's like really blonde
like i guess i should do it for another
couple minutes and i remember like
putting it down and like
i could feel like this like warmth and
like heat like almost on my head i'm
like ah like that's starting to hurt a
lot you know and i opened my eyes like
while it was like in the like close to
the bowl i remember like my eyes
immediately were burning and i like
popped my head up and i'm like oh my god
like my hair's gone
i saw this huge chunk of [ __ ] he was
like not only was it like a patch of
like burnt skin but it was like like
little wisps like like
blonde translucent like wisps my hair
was down to here you know what i mean so
it's like just this like you know not
not the biggest chunk but it's like
having a missing tooth like nobody's
gonna miss that [ __ ] so
i just had this moment of like surreal
panic where i'm like i know i'm dreaming
i'm like this is not happening i didn't
[ __ ] just burn off my hair and my
parents said no i'm tweaking so like i
had like i panicked and was like oh my
god i ha like i have this black hair
that i have to like dye all my hair
black to like
like cover that because it's less comb
over i basically had a comb over i dyed
it black but the thing is like ammonia
isn't like there was something
in the the hair product itself like
on this flesh wound that i just gave
myself like turns out if you put ammonia
on it it's like ah you know so i'm
sitting there and like my parents were
going through like financial
difficulties that are at the time we
were about to like foreclose their heads
like they have their own like world of
stresses and they come home and they're
like [ __ ] like what are you
doing in here like there's like because
i you know to this day i get hair
uh dye all over the bathroom when i do
this but it was like
you know black hair dye splattered out
of this bathroom and i'm thinking like i
fixed this problem and they're like what
the [ __ ] are you doing like you you
ruined the bathroom like this is not
they're just like lambasting like i'm
just like i already want to die like and
you just could you would wait like a day
for you know could you just let's just
shift this uh
verbal tongue lashing to the next day or
something but i mean i swear to god like
i was like i want to end my life that
was probably like you know it's like
this is the worst thing that could
happen to me
i lost eight inches of hair
did you stick with the comb over or like
dude i sort of gotta convince like it
people would be like oh like you have
like blood or it's like a scab on your
face i'm like oh yeah it was because
like i left this in too long and there's
ammonia you know like
i think i told a couple people but like
if something's dark enough it kind of
just looks like a flat like you don't
even mean it like adds density to the
look do you have any pictures of it
no cause it all would have been like you
know
no i wish i could there weren't cameras
back then we didn't have cameras back
then yeah exactly
oh my god what the [ __ ] was i talking
about so anyway
that's all to say this dude i had this
little argument with the dude who's like
frosted tips and then they're like oh it
seems like i hit a nerve it's like no no
i'm correcting you like i don't have fri
you can't start this argument with like
you have frost tips and that's the what
i'm predicting this entire
roast on and it's like well it turns out
so i just don't like i have you can
roast me for gray hair there's a million
things you could roast me on physically
you went with frosted hair and then i
said i don't have frosted hair and
you're like ha
but
you do have frosted hair it's like oh
god be smarter my haters
just level up
take the l
do some research open your eyes i don't
think my hair looks like it's frosted
does it i mean do i look like i [ __ ]
go to a
does this look planned
[Laughter]
oh my god let's go to hell the
personality portion of the podcast last
time we talked about enfjs i'm going to
go through all of these personality
types i want to do the intj architect
this is really interesting type to me i
met with a guy who was an intj on friday
a friend of the guy
joshua was talking about before
and uh joshua wanted us to meet
and i'm like yeah okay like and then we
finally met up i didn't know exactly
what it was for but like
when you meet an intj they're just so
impressive intellectually and like as
problem solvers and i think here's an
interesting little factoid they get
disproportionately represented as
villains in movies because they're kind
of like the
do you see my master plan if i do this
like
they they can come off as sort of
maybe
cold blunt direct unfeeling
you know there's certain traits that if
you exaggerate this like you know you
get a sociopath but intjs are generally
have moral compasses it's just doesn't
align necessarily with the rest of
society so if they don't feel like
emotion or have some big reaction to
something because they're like stoic and
introverted people be like oh my god
you're a dick you're unfeeling but i
know a lot of intjs are just like they
don't react to things but that's one of
their big strengths is because they can
think through
large problems without any
clouding of emotional attachments
they're great at looking at
contingencies and kind of going like
here's all the possibilities that would
arise from this
you know potential actions you could
take in response to this problem they're
great computer programmers this
particular guy like writes music
very successfully with some big artists
like michael jackson and stevie wonder
but then he also does like
tech stuff like his invented software
for like blind people to make music and
algorithms and all that stuff so i'm
always so impressed oh also he wrote the
hot pocket jingle
he's the guy that jim gaffigan's joking
about hot pockets hot pocket well he
does the whole bit he's like what do you
got steve it's like ah
oh my pocket i like it perfect not as
good as your bi-menon but
um
so
he's the you know i guess there is to
his credit a longer full song but like
he's the hot pocket guy and he said
there was a buy-out he's like if there
wasn't for this buy-out they didn't
there was no option for you know
royalties but he's like
you know it could have been like six
million dollars of royalties at uh
the rate that they have used that little
jingle
okay maybe i should actually read a
little bit about this intj stuff huh
i'll be real quick actually let's get to
the famous ones first i was like oh elon
musk such an intj michelle obama perhaps
christopher nolan for sure
friedrich anita
every college student's favorite
philosopher vladimir putin that makes
sense arnold schwarzenegger that makes
sense
colin powell uh yeah okay i can see that
samantha power i don't think i know
walter white that makes sense because
he's a scientist and a criminal
mastermind and those two things go
together um
peter baelish littlefinger in game of
thrones i [ __ ] didn't watch that too
long ago and i forget who the hell that
is
uh tywin lannister as an intj
and gandalf the gray is an intj okay
katniss
there's so many of these okay i didn't
mean to do all that but
it gives you an idea this personality
type
whenever i hear vladimir putin speak i'm
like this guy's really intelligent and
uh i do think he acts from a sort of
detached place he's great at calculation
and
certain forms of strategy by all
accounts like when i hear him
you know the translated version of his
russian impromptu speeches like
he's
intjs make great debate partners for
entps so i'm always drawn to them
because we can discuss ideas in a
similar way with a similar language and
a great desire to be right but uh elon
musk is like the classic intj super
villain kind of guy who's like
you know set on world domination and you
know making rocket ships and changing
the world and becoming a billionaire so
let's read this intro real quick
it could be lonely at the top as one of
the rarest personality types and one of
the most capable architects intjs know
this all too uh rational and
quick-witted architects may struggle to
find people who can keep up with their
non-stop analysis of everything around
them so yes i have an appetite for that
so if you put me around an intj it's
like i like to at least be the recipient
of their expertise and knowledge and
hear how they think about things and
solve problems because they're just
really good
problem solvers
um
they can take ideas and like make them
happen and they're very driven to like
fix the problem i might be like uh
here's an idea for what you could do but
i don't have any interest in actually
doing it
a thirst for knowledge these
personalities can be both the boldest of
dreamers and the bitterest of pessimists
architects believe that through
willpower and intelligence they can
achieve even the most challenging of
goals but they may be cynical about
human nature more generally very true
assuming that most people are lazy
unimaginative or simply doomed to
mediocrity here's one on top of my head
ben shapiro is an intj
so if you think about him that's a good
role model of that
architects drive much of their
self-esteem from their knowledge and
mental acuity in school people with this
personality type may have been called
bookworms or nerds but rather than
taking these labels as insults many
architects embrace them they are
confident in their ability to teach
themselves about and master any topic
that interests them whether or not
whether that's coding or capoeira or
classical music architects can be
single-minded with little patience for
frivolity distractions or idle gossip
very true these people will
they're not much for small talk it's
like get to the point and to the point
where it may come across as rude or
blunt but the intentions are good it's
like let's get to the ideas let's get to
the facts stop wasting my time
that said it would be a mistake to
stereotype these personalities as dull
or humorless many architects are known
for their irreverent wit and beneath
their serious exteriors they often have
a sharp delightfully sarcastic sense of
humor yes i enter it's often a very dark
sense of humor and one of the things
i'll say about christopher nolan is all
these movies it's like there's such a
level of complexity and multi-layered
um storytelling that this i'm like i'm
astounded that he keeps it on his head
it's like you wrote this and like you
directed the movie
knowing all these component parts like
in your head all at once and there's
such precision with everything that he
does like he's just not a sloppy
filmmaker in the slightest did you watch
the prestige yeah
oh god
it's like one of my favorite movies of
all time and this is like
so complex as far as storytime but also
like ethically it's like there's this
amazing like you know very clear
ethical message of like
winning and accomplishing things through
tremendous sacrifice versus through uh
selfish and greedy mechanisms that you
know harm other people like killing your
you know clone every night or whatever
versus like giving up your life to a
twin did you see uh tenet
no is that good it's awesome so at first
i hated it i couldn't get through it
and then i was like let me watch it
again
it was like warm at least finished it
the second time i've probably watched it
15 times wow and i like it more and more
every time but i was amazing
didn't like it to the point of i'm not
finishing this i was like how long is it
uh it's pretty i don't know it's like
two hours
okay so nothing it wasn't like this is
too long i can't no it wasn't about the
length it was just like i don't
understand what's going on i feel stupid
i get it you're smart christopher nolan
i'm dumb this sucks i hate being stupid
but then the more i watched it i was
like this is yes that's always really
cool when you don't like a movie at
first and then watch it and like it not
that this is a similar movie but in
college i call that the zoolander effect
because a bunch of my friends got and
seen zoolander and they're like it was
so stupid and not funny
and then i watched it again for some
reason like why would you go and see a
movie that you thought was shitty and
then be like i'm gonna pay money to go
see it again but that barely happened a
number of times and it happened to me
um
and i was like actually this is the
greatest movie i've ever seen and then i
would you know quote it for the rest of
my life so
it is but it is like it's like almost
like you're missing something or what
hot american summer is another one that
i think people will watch and like what
like you know if you're not prepared or
you don't didn't know the like the guys
from the state on mtv back in the day
um
but pulling dynamite probably another
one where people get caught off guard
like what is that is this yeah yeah yeah
like it takes a second to adjust to the
tone of the comedy for example i think
is more but um
that's exciting about tennant i
definitely need to watch it okay i'm
gonna do a real quick hella chef harley
this is another super simple one
that you're gonna be like this is
repetitive because you've done greek
yogurt-based recipes before but this is
just one that i've done recently because
it's
so simple it's like if you have five
minutes and you're rushing out the door
and you do like
you know short of making a pre-made
protein shake this is one of the
quickest options for good macros
and it's filling and you know if you're
running out you know you're not going to
be back for like a while this will fill
you up
and it's not that many calories but it's
still very filling and high protein so
you're going to do some greek yogurt
some almond butter and some honey
maybe you want to throw in a little
frozen fruit in there too but that's the
basic thing that you mix all together
and it creates this nice consistency
like and the flavors just really work
together
uh
you know probably a tablespoon what did
i put down there yes if you do three
tablespoons of almond butter
one tablespoon of honey 2.5 cups of
greek yogurt that's going to be 679
calories
it's going to be 40 protein
24 carbs 35 percent fat
of cal uh you know that's the caloric
breakdown the split there
and it's going to be 72 grams of protein
that's a lot
27 grams of fat
not too bad and 41 grams of carbs so you
got a pretty good little meal there
literally you know if you took three
minutes
to put that all together and stir it up
i'd be shocked and i eat fast but i
think you could still like you know
you're just putting in your mouth and
swelling you don't have to chew so
that's another element of this
efficiency try it out it's a good
breakfast
okay
i'm gonna go back real quick too
hell a sec i promised you guys i would
tell the first story of me
doing
lsd it was a terrible experience
i had to move the next day
i didn't want to do drugs i went to my
friend harrison's house who i told you
he lives in san francisco
and
he recently passed away i was there with
my girlfriend he had taken in this like
slovenian homeless kid the street urchin
who like was visiting and stayed over
his visa whatever
and i guess the kid was sort of
interesting and charismatic but i
quickly determined like this kid was
quite narcissistic like in the way he
would like
debate me or debate this other guy in
the room my friend tim who's a a lawyer
but he's very nice but he was like very
condescending to tim as if his like
niceness meant he was like stupid you
know like he's sort of confusing like
cordiality or politeness or
open-mindedness with like intellectual
weakness so i could tell this guy it's
like
it's very
grandiose and thought of himself as like
you know kind of the smartest guy in the
room with no formal education and but
based on things like i understand like
the you know the 911 conspiracy is
better and i'm i like you know so anyway
i'll talk about that in a second because
that was like the first step in a really
weird interaction but at first it was
like oh who's the slovenian kid that
you've like decided to you know you met
and like took it and you think you're
doing a you know good thing but i can
immediately tell i'm like harrison this
guy is taking advantage of you um
he does not have your best interest in
mind and i'm predicting that there's
going to be problems and there was but
that night
i was like hey like kid who's doing
drugs all the time
uh and living in the you know golden
gate park can you get me some mushrooms
he's like no you don't want mushrooms
like you want lsd lsd's fire blah blah
like i got the fire ship all while like
just pushing pushing pushing pushing
like i really just want some shrooms to
like
do later like i'm not interested in lsd
i've never done it before and just kept
pushing pushing pushing
let's go to the golden gate park like
let's go down like i want to go around a
bunch of homeless people and do
psychedelics right now sorry homeless
people but um and i had to move the next
day you know like all these things are
like you know
but i think i'd already taken like
an edible
and an adderall which is
not a great combination to then you know
what it ended up doing was taking lsd on
it um because of the anxiety factor
that's what i'm going to say both
adderall and edibles can increase your
anxiety so it's already parting a little
bit but then you add lsd that this sort
of
uh you know he basically he went and
procured the lsd and then he convinced
me and my girlfriend
uh
like
and she was like he was like doing it
really hard like trying to manipulate
her really hard like dude do it dude
like let's do it come on and you just
wouldn't relent i'm like all right fine
dude let's [ __ ]
you know let's do some lsd
and uh you know shouldn't have done that
but took it and
um
immediately start out with this as i
promised the 911 conspiracy talk and
i'm good at impromptu
debates like that
just by not by virtue of expertise but
by virtue of
directing somebody towards the path
where they're going to admit that they
don't have the expertise to make the
point that they're making because if
you're talking about like
jet fuel doesn't melt steel beams or
something like that and it's like well
are you a physicist like do you have any
degree in physics or anything like that
because you know what the easiest
rebuttal to that is like well at extreme
heats you know steel starts to bend it
doesn't have to melt to actually um
compromise the integrity of the
structure that's like the basic rebuttal
to like i don't know if you've ever
heard 911 conspiracy stuff but like you
know it's blown up in its own thing like
it couldn't
they're all rebuttal a bull but i love
when people act that's like oh suddenly
you're a physics professor please tell
me more about how buildings fall you
know with 100 certainty um so i don't
need it's like i i don't think there is
like i understand why people you know
have been obsessed with 9 11
conspiracies that is
like don't think people understand the
magnitude of conspiracy like that you
can make an algorithm that predicts like
there's would need to be this many
people and it would last like because of
that like each additional person like
exponentially increases the likelihood
it's gonna get exposed in a certain
amount of time because like we could
keep a conspiracy add two add three at
four
fifty a hundred people it's like
somebody's gonna say something
over some time or slip up in some way
so that's another element but
i sort of like got him on that like the
final word was like
you know
and your physics professor and he's like
like i already like slammed the table it
was like knew he lost but was like so
like
trying to like after that he was like
trying to like
get me in some weird way and i found out
later like as we were like hanging out
like i'd go to the bathroom and he would
like throw a note to my girlfriend like
um
like i want to be with you it's
something like he was like hitting on my
girlfriend which made her super
uncomfortable when i come back and
there's like a weird vibe of the room
but i was like
you know this is all my first time on
lsd and i'm like there's something like
just really uncomfortable around here
but you're like acting like everything's
normal and you're like no stay like keep
staying and i'm like god it's getting
late like you know moving and he kept
you know i hate when people try to
convince you of things like that's
another sign of narcissism is like
people going like no no this is in your
best interest when it's very much not in
your best interest whatsoever
i finally had to like rip myself up like
as everyone's tripping back dude i have
to go right now we were moving tomorrow
haley it was like like i pulled the plug
on like a disco or something i remember
the supposed
[Music]
like this guy's [ __ ] like i didn't
say that but i was like you know the
point of me getting up was like i feel
very uncomfortable around this person
right here he is very off in a major way
that nobody else seems to see but i
can't like be like hey this person has
narcissistic personality disorder i'm
going to define that and then list all
those characteristics for you so we can
get out the door that's an awkward
conversation to have high on lsd and
edibles and adderall
but i finally got out
and then
there was the follow-up to it as i got
down like i just felt so much relief
because like you know when you you're
around somebody with like a
dark tried personality disorder they
just kind of give you the heebie-jeebies
because everything has like a hidden
agenda you know you can't like ever take
what they're saying for face value and
often they're making some sort of subtle
dig at you
so a few weeks later he like needed a
ride to uh my girlfriend was going to la
and this guy like
emailed her like somehow got in touch
with her and was like i could really use
like a ride to l.a like please don't
tell mark i know he doesn't like me yada
yada and like
she was gullible enough to be like okay
i'm like doing this guy favor he's
homeless he doesn't have any resources
to get down there he really needs it and
uh
like
you know
i found out she didn't tell me and i
found out from it because like he
emailed her back something like
referring to the riot i was like what
the [ __ ] is this like and
it turns out like she was like i'm so
disgusted by like what happened like i
thought i was giving a ride he stunk so
bad in the car and he was like admitted
that he was like just trying to have sex
with me and he wants to be with me and i
was like you gross like i'm not you know
and i believed her like this kid did
smell like absolute garbage and i don't
think i'd ever had sex with a girl
before
but he did tell me that he lived in
amsterdam
by allowing an older guy to blow him
every night so he could stay in his
apartment so
that all leads to this final part of the
story
because i was pissed about this i'm like
that little [ __ ] like went behind my
back manipulated my girlfriend like made
her super uncomfortable
and it's caused tension between us so a
couple weeks after that
something happened where like
whoever does these immigration raids
they like they did something over you
know the golden gate park all these
homeless people and he like ran
and got caught like he like fled the
scene when like maybe the police are
showing up then they apprehend him and
they're like oh you're staying over your
visa you know um
we're gonna put you in this immigration
detention center
so he was like locked up facing legal
trouble you know it is like it's very
bad if you get caught like in the
country like breaking laws and then
you're
over your visa
at harrison's i was doing some work for
harrison
and saw that his uh his facebook was
locked in
so i my revenge on him was to post this
thing that was like from his perspective
like
help guys like i'm in a detention center
uh because i overstayed my visa like i'm
really scared like i just want to go
back to sucking
men's dicks in amsterdam to live for
free like i made some reference to it
you know to be like i'm gonna put like
something that i hope embarrasses you
publicly uh and shows you know what a
little grifter you are and you know
probably some other details but i just
like posted that publicly for all his
friends on facebook you know like oh and
i used like google translate to put it
in slovenian so it's like people were
like wait a second this just sounds like
it's google trends like are you okay uh
yvonne like you know
but it was like one of my favorite troll
moments and like his sister got in
contact with me sister i guess is super
normal and cool was like dude i know
he's like a complete [ __ ] [ __ ]
like she was like can you help me like
get in contact with them i'm like your
brother is like a b c d and you know e
this horrible person
and
i don't want to help him and she's like
i know he's been like that his whole
life i'm like okay i can work with that
you know let's uh i want to help you out
you seem like a good person but
you know
don't [ __ ] with me and then leave your
facebook account open
i wanted to do a saucy or not this week
on possibly my favorite new artist i had
seen this guy before
oliver tree in blake weber's videos um
let's pause it there for a second
like where he's he's shirtless so this
is like i s i forget where i saw this
but i oh i think i saw him doing an
ethan klein interview and he had the
funny hair and [ __ ] i'm like that's
hilarious but i thought this he was
doing like a character called turbo in
the world of blake webb i just saw this
funny looking dude like jinko jeans in a
bowl cut so he's doing this like weird
90s kid he looks like an 11 year old in
1998 basically
and
this is a different character form but
he would do i didn't realize he's like a
legitimate artist because
he's such a good
like performance artist and sticking to
these characters and making these
amazing video aesthetics like i'm legit
impressed
now
let's see his physique right here
because
something's off man i i feel like oliver
tree
you have made an astounding physique
change in the last couple years when you
were rocking that turbo character
you were skinny fat you were out of
shape you didn't have any muscle you in
fact you looked significantly shorter i
don't know if that's an optical illusion
here but look at the fullness of the
pecs right and of course we have good
downward lighting but he's got very well
developed quads
we can see even though he's covering his
junk with his hat we see prominent
abdominals we see very full delts and
traps we see
large biceps and triceps now maybe to
the average viewer you wouldn't look at
this physique and go oh he's on steroids
he's just working out he just looks like
a normal buff dude he's very lean very
muscular very full and again the
starting point for oliver tree
is a guy who's
five foot seven
a buck fifty
25 body fat and all of a sudden he's
6'3 240
7 body fat i mean does that seem natural
to you christian
yeah so there's so much going on you
like
maybe he hadn't hit puberty yet and he
took growth hormone to to get taller we
played a little bit more we'll get a
better view
and are we allowed to play music at all
either
okay
he goes i'm not good at goodbye look at
this
we can see more veins now we can see the
abs more clearly those quads are full
[ __ ] bicep vein just running down
there upper packs really full and
engorged and that's when you know it's
like when somebody's got not just the
pec but like the full upper pack just
looks like it's popping out right there
and god damn and even kind of you know
he's still got that puffy face looks
like he's on some d-ball maybe right a
little water retention dead giveaway so
you know what oliver i'm still a fan of
your music
cowboys don't cry it's still my favorite
song right now that i'm listening on
repeat but i'm going to be honest with
you
i know you're on steroids
okay
and i wish you'd just be honest with
people because in the music industry the
fans appreciate authenticity and so if
you give them a little bit more of that
i think it'll only benefit you okay we
accept you for who you are
and i'm not trying to take away from
your hard work in the gym to create such
a dramatic transformation putting on 60
pounds of muscle and eight inches of
height in the span of only a couple
years okay
all right
what's up next i said
i would do a help on monsters where i
talk about my first steroid cycle we're
gonna do that in a second how about we
do some
why we can't have nice gyms
how about that huh
this girl this girl jumps up on like
what is that
an 18 inch box maybe you know
12 to 18 inches
it falls underneath her feet and she
falls on her ass and i'm going to
delight in this because you get to go
did you think about that beforehand like
this isn't a super stable surface nor do
you need to jump on a box when it's only
it's like just jump up just jump up 12
inches and come down
you know the point of some of these
plyometrics is like if you're jumping so
high
that you come down and it's like this
tremendous impact on your knees that you
want to save yourself from by jumping
onto the high thing
that's one thing or if you're jumping
off you know
like off of a really high platform to
work on the deceleration
which is another form of plyometric work
you know jumping from high to low to
stop yourself sort of
explosively reverse explosively i don't
know what the terminology is
but in this case that box isn't
necessary just jump up and down rather
than doing a box jump for 12 inches
just jump and then squat and then jump
again all right and this next one is
this girl playing around there's some
sort of pulling mechanism she goes let's
her body go all the way back and then
she swings right through the door and
again another one of these things we go
did you think about what would happen
when you go to the ground
and there's more tension
in those pulleys
than your weight
right so if you're a hundred and you
know five pounds like this girl probably
is
you'd wanna think about what's going to
happen
when i go limp or really what happens is
she's going back at this angle
and then her feet slip which uh you know
changes the direction of the force so
uh that she's suddenly pulled
forward really quickly and that door is
like remarkably there's so many things
going on where it's like
you know you you brought that upon
yourself you weren't thinking and so i
have no sympathy for you i like the
commitment to hold on to that i know
it's like you can just let go uh yeah
yeah she could have just like why were
you holding on like through the door
like the moment you're getting pulled
it's like let go
um
all right
i'm gonna do a quick bro science academy
because i you know this is the thing
about working out so it's just a quick
one because i had a
training session with my client
yesterday who does mostly home workouts
he's got a pull-up bar but that's pretty
much it he was having some neck issues
from doing pull-ups and like straining
his neck and kind of cramping up his
trapezius into his neck and you know
which can happen like when you spend too
much time in that contracted position
and you don't consciously relax these
kind of injuries and strains can happen
so what we focused on
this last session was
pausing going at tempo focusing on our
breathing you know consciously relaxing
your your neck during all the reps that
we did of push-ups staggered push-ups
dead hang pull-ups
i worked with them a lot on like let's
do a dead hang and then you do a pull-up
all the way you know explosively come
back down
breathe relax your necks reset when you
go from doing fast pull ups to for
example you know a three second dead
hang all the way up and come back down
it's remarkable the kind of workout you
can get in just a few reps when you take
for example crunches
you can do a set of ten
crunches where you contract for five
seconds right it's just ten crunches but
each one you hold for five seconds at
the top like somebody's about to hit you
in the stomach all you need is ten i can
do maybe a couple sets of those but when
you're
creating that tension you can lower the
reps you don't need to use weight and
you can still get a very effective
workout
same thing with pacing your movements
like if you do a pull up and you go i'm
maybe going to cut a little bit off the
top and off the bottom of this range of
motion but i'm going to commit to going
to a super steady pace where the
the positive looks like the negative
and i'm just going back and forth in
this controlled pace i'm not bouncing or
dropping or doing anything like that
that also drastically reduces the number
of reps you need to get a good workout
apply that to push-ups too maybe do like
a three-second pause at the very bottom
of a push-up then all of a sudden a set
of 10 is really phenomenally difficult
so if you're sick of like accumulating
all these reps or you think you can't
make something hard enough at home in a
certain amount of time try pausing
try tempo and that also works in the gym
too i've been implementing that a lot of
my lat pull-down work
going really straight coming down and
holding and putting back up and you can
cut that weight down by 30 percent and
still get a jackpot because okay
i bring up my back because look at this
physique check god you know sometimes i
hate my body sometimes i love it this is
a picture that i just really like with
the catcher in the background
my delts are coming in i've been working
on my traps by contracting my scapula on
all my real movements i feel like uh you
know not a bad body part right now okay
give me a break
it's hard for me i don't have the best
genetics
i was born in the soviet union
but when they were all out of drugs
performance enhancing
drugs i just experienced the poverty and
i came over here and i didn't lift
weights until last year but look what
i've been able to do it's incredible
right thank you for agreeing with me so
a lot of stuff we didn't get to that's
cool because i'm going to set it up for
next week aren't i
we're still waiting on that dmt we're
still you know we're still going to do
it okay so you know we need learning
hasn't done the dnt yet i'm going
somebody send me the dmt and i'll do it
i don't have the dmt
maybe if you're if you're cool you could
send it to me no actually don't
definitely don't send me dmt do not do
that at all please definitely don't do
that i would hate for that to happen
that's the last thing i want to happen
is somebody's sending me dmt okay
so please definitely don't do that all
right
thank you now we're going to end on this
i appreciate everybody listening
i want to start doing more books i want
to start talking about
stuff that's more abstract intellectual
if you want okay we're also going to do
more of this psychedelic stuff each week
and i'm going to get that dmt and yes i
am actually going to do it
the thing is
i take my shirt off
every episode right i thought i'd switch
it up today because
i got some phenomenal quads and i just
want to make sure that you guys
know what's up okay
we gonna focus in on here we're gonna
can you see that
can we
can we get a little
can we
ah
what's up dude you really thought that i
wouldn't take off my pants for the
haters will say episode 21 you're legal
now so i'm taking off my pants i'll see
you next week